you're not playing it safe here in heels
and given the fact that you just got out
of hospital that's pretty risky Priyanka
but I can a girl go to an old red carpet
without heels don't tell my doctor that
you'll give me a call tomorrow you
shouldn't no let's just say I'm in
sneakers and when he sees the pictures I
say oops I forgot it was a concussion
photoshopped it it was I got hurt on my
head so I'm supposed to like forget
things excuse me how are you feeling
what happened it was a I was doing
stunts and it was raining that night and
or snowing whatever in New York and I
was wearing rubber boots and it was such
a stupid way to I've done so many stunts
before and I've never got hurt but I
slipped on a wet road while I was saving
someone else another co actor of mine
and I hit my head to the bump of the car
and the road so then I was taken to the
ER and they did a cat scan and they said
it was a concussion so I did take three
days off work
and I just sit on my couch and literally
just listen to audiobooks and I was
listening to Amy Schumer talk to me
through the weekend cuz I was reading
her I'm listening to her book boos I
wasn't supposed to I couldn't watch TV I
couldn't read a book so I just had Amy
Schumer in my ears the whole pretty good
way to recover by she was awesome well I
was laughing out loud looking at the
roof alone on my couch let me ask you
this will the accident affect how you'll
do stunts moving forward didn't go
affect you in any way no I just have to
I just have to wear my brace for a
couple days and when I'm
[Music]
you